tres flores florecieron ayer y dibujaron
las flores
12 36 más florecieron hoy 123456 cuántas
flores florecieron bueno 3 ayer y 6 más
hoy así que tendrás las 3 de ayer más
las 6 de hoy aquí es igual 36 bueno 36
es lo mismo que 6 + 3 y eso será igual a
9 6 1 y 7 6 + 2 es 8 639 y es bueno
saberlo tenerlo en tu cabeza 6 339 36 es
9 o puedes contar las incluso 123456789
hagamos otro
había dos tiburones uno dos tres
tiburones más llegaron 123 cuántos
tiburones hay ahora bueno están los dos
que estuvieron allí antes más los tres
que vinieron así que ahora hay dos más
tres tiburones cuanto estos más 32 más
35 23 es 5 y puedes contar los 1 2 3 4 5
hagamos uno más
una ardilla recolectó siete bellotas 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 tomó una bellota más
averigua cuántas bellotas recolectó
recolectó las siete más una bellota más
serían siete más una bellotas y eso es
igual a 8 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
la tuvimos bien